we're gonna start off this hour with
Caitlyn and Baltimore Maryland hi
Caitlyn how are you hi Dave I'm great
thank you so much for taking my call and
thank you for your message and your
mission and helping people change their
lives thank you how can I help
so I'm 24 I'm single I'm a college
graduate I graduated from a four-year
state school three years ago I have a
bachelor's degree and I'm currently
making 46 thousand a year I'm debt free
so I'm on baby step three right I have a
number of financial future goals so I
want to get a new car eventually because
right now I'm in a 2003 beater that's
three different colors I want to own a
home but I don't necessarily know the
cost I should expect I want to travel
fund and eventually I want to raise my
own kids so my question is how do I do
the math now how do I set my financial
targets now to make sure that I'm on
track to meet those goals when I look at
my savings to figure out how much to
save and by when and when I look at my
salary figuring out you know what kind
of salary join me need to aim towards
each year and basically figuring out you
know what will you do now to move
towards hitting those goals well some of
them are very clear and you could put an
exact dollar amount to and then you just
put a timeline on them and then other
others are a little bit more vague you
know I want to have kids that was a
little more vague in terms of you can't
you know it's not exact dollar amount
we've put on that but we don't want to
buy a car I want to move up in car well
boom you can do that right I mean you
just you can set that goal exactly this
is the car I want this is how much it
costs and this is how much time it's
gonna save me to take me to save up the
money to pay for the car and so you know
I think the ones that you can make very
very clear then you just have to
prioritize them and say this one's first
this one's second this one's third and
so on down the list and that sets you up
to you know be able to chip away at the
different ones but you know being
financially independent as a goal you
know I mean that's a little vague you
kind of have to say okay what does that
mean and how do I get there and you kind
of got to start backing into how much do
I need to save
you know to have a nest egg to live off
of or what do I call independence you
know you gotta have you gotta have to
kind of break it down that way but I
think you're way ahead of the game
number one you actually are smart enough
to ask the question number two you have
you know you've already won in that
you're debt-free and have your emergency
fund in place and then you know so
you're just way ahead of the game you're
gonna do just fine
don't fret don't fret but but be smart
and and begin to lay those goals out you
won't hit them if you don't set them so
you're smart to lay that out but I think
you just decide which one's first which
one's second which one's third and and
you know or are we gonna do a couple of
them simultaneously work towards them
simultaneously and you'll be just fine
doing that so very cool very very very
well done hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel tell
that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you